[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Фрумушика була дуже великим селом.
У ньому було 540 подвір'їв,
5 млинів,
[Бессарабія,
Фрумушинка-Нова]
2 школи, училище, церква була,
протікала річка Фрумушика.
Тут, насправді, дуже велика суміш національностей.
[Михайло Паларієв
Співзасновник етнографічного центру]
Мати може бути болгаркою,
батько — молдаванином,
діти невідомо які.
Усі розуміють молдавську, болгарську,
російську, українську мови.
Така тут цікава земля.
Я кажу, що я на 51% молдаванин.
Тато — молдаванин, мати — українка.
Але, повірте, в душі, там, де потрібно,
я українець, на 200 відсотків.
[Олександр Паларієв
Співзасновник етнографічного центру]
В 1946 році тут був заснований
танковий військовий полігон.
При заснуванні цього полігону
виселили п'ять сіл:
Кантемир, Зурум, Рошия, Кофрумсталь і Фрумушика.
Уродженцем Фрумушики був мій дідусь.
Ви можете їхати степом до полігону
і побачите купу різних снарядів
Це те, заради чого були зруйновані села.
Минуло рівно 60 років.
Ми взяли ці землі в оренду.
І почали будувати комплекс,
який в майбутньому стане
музеєм просто неба «Бесарабське село».
Усе почалось 06.06.2006.
Голий степ.
Немає нічого, ані води, ані світла,
ані цегли, нічого.
Побудували спочатку першу ферму.
Один гостьовий будиночок, щоб там ночувати.
Люди почали до нас в гості приїжджати.
Батько говорить: «Приїжджайте, приїжджайте».
Урешті-решт, вийшло дуже гарне місце.
Ніхто не розумів, що все це збудується.
Ніхто цього не проєктував.
Проєкт був — вівчарство.
Є світова статистика, яка говорить, що вівчарство —
найзбитковіша галузь сільського господарства.
Мінус 37% від вкладених коштів.
Знаєте, тут вже справа принципу.
Якось шкода перед хлопцями підняти руки.
Коли ми починали наш вівчарський бізнес,
а саме: розведення овець каракульської породи,
це мало своє економічне обґрунтування.
Ми брали наш каракуль,
віддавали німцям,
вони виробляли хутро, відправляли нам,
ми отримували сертифікат, відправляли в Італію.
В Одесі є салон хутряних виробів,
так і називається — «Palari Furs».
Хто ж знав, що буде криза 2008-09 років?
По-друге, хто ж думав про війну?
80% хутряних виробів світу продається в Росії.
Ми вирішили продавати нашу продукцію не просто
як м'ясо, як молочні продукти чи сировину.
А вирішили побудувати мережу кафе та ресторанів,
які продають нашу продукцію.
Таким чином ми вирішили знайти
додаткову додану вартість.
Більше диверсифікації іде на музейний
та туристичний комплекси.
Якби це було тільки вівчарство,
ми би одразу занепали.
Я отримую задоволення від того,
що у дітей щось виходить,
що вони теж заряджені на першість.
У нашій бідній країні завжди хочеться
хоч у чомусь бути «дуже».
А як зробити, щоб ми були
в Книзі рекордів Гіннеса першими?
Найперша за відвідуваністю —
Статуя Свободи на острові Еліс,
це Лежачий Будда,
по-моєму в Малайзії.
В Україні немає жодного пам'ятника,
який входить до Книги рекордів Гіннеса
Значить треба в одній локації
побудувати два пам'ятники.
Питають одразу: «А хто чи що буде?»
Найбільший пам'ятник собаці.
Зробимо його висотою 6,8 - 7,8 метрів.
Пропорційно чабану.
Візьмемо нашу дворнягу,
поїдемо в сусіднє село, сфотографуємо.
Зробимо її з такими вухами.
Цих грошей вистачить на 500 метрів дороги. І все.
Кілометр дороги.
Це нічого, бо треба 18 кілометрів дороги зробити.
Так краще зробити об'єкт, до якого дорогу повинні будуть прокласти.
Для того, щоб акумулювати це зі самого початку,
коли ніхто не думав про те, що треба їх забирати.
Раніше цього не було.
Ми просто платили гроші.
За метр пам'ятника умовно 700 гривень.
І так звозили, скуповували.
Таким чином з'явився музей радянської епохи.
Зараз із цим легше,
бо зараз привозять самі або просять,
щоб ми забрали.
У Литві є музей таких пам'ятників.
Пам'ятників соцреалізму.
Туди, я бачив, люди приходять.
Це туристичне місце.
Це не значить, що я якийсь там комуніст.
Ну ви розумієте, якщо 12 людей
Паларієвих виселили з Фрумушики.
Повернулась одна дівчинка.
Через це моє прізвище Паларія.
А бабуся, щоб врятуватися,
змінила прізвище на Паларієв.
Влаштувалась, сховалась, перефарбувалась.
І вони врятувались.
Молдавське подвір'я повністю побудоване
за ескізами дому,
в якому жив дідусь, з якого його виселили.
Я кажу: «Тато, намалюй подвір'я,
в якому ти народився».
Він намалював.
Прийшли сюди, він заплакав, я заплакав.
Так це подвір'я народилось.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Марія Теребус]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтаж
Марія Теребус]
[Музика
Шагани, Чаламада, Sasha Boole]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]